Thank you, everyone,
for coming today.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm a Developer Advocate at
Google focusing on gaming and
web technologies in general.
You see my email address here,
colton@google.com.
And we are here today to
talk about a very,
very important topic.
We're here to talk about
texture compression.
Now before we get too started,
I'm going to need to see a
show of hands.
How many of you in here have
actually shipped a product, a
video game, on a console?
So Xbox 360, PS3, Nintendo
DS for that matter?
OK, good.
So out of those hands--
you can put them down and
we'll get a new set--
out of those hands, how many of
you have ever fought with
texture footprint in memory?
OK, Good.
Good, good, good.
So obviously, you know that
compressing your textures is a
big problem and that, most
importantly, you spend a lot
of time trying to fight your
memory constraints against
what your artists
are producing.
Well today, we're here to talk
about that specifically.
And what we want to talk about
is DXT is not enough.
Now I know there's hardware
architecture differences with
compressed textures and
PVR and ECT and
all these other things.
So I hope you take what we're
talking about today and how
it's being applied
to DXT texturing.
And I hope you apply it to some
of these other things
that may be platform-specific.
So all right, let's
get started then.
So texture footprints matters
for games, as we've already
talked about this.
How many times have you been
down to the wire or down to
memory and needed an extra five
megabytes for animations
or 10 megabytes for sound?
And you go back and you do your
statistic gathering and
find that your losing 50% or
60% of your entire memory
footprint just for
texture assets.
And there's tons of different
reasons for this.
They could need to
be high-res.
Or there could be too
many MIP chains.
Or the artists author them at
2048's when they only occupy a
64x64 pixel set on the screen.
Whatever the reasons, right?
For us, this is a big problem
because, as a console
developer, you spend a lot
of time fighting this.
Retail doesn't really care
a lot about this, though.
There's a great article--
I forget which site posted
it-- where John Carmack
actually went to the head of
their publisher at the time
and said, hey, I've got an
amazing new technology.
It's called MegaTexture.
And it's awesome.
You can stream in
infinite detail.
And it's fantastic.
The problem is that we're now
looking at 17 gigabytes of
data just for one game.
And in the article, it actually
says that the head of
the publisher said, hey,
that's fantastic.
I love it.
This will push our Blu-ray
sales for video games.
The point of this is that, for
retail developers, that's
good, right?
They're giving out this physical
medium and pushing
this physical medium to consoles
and to PC developers
the 17-gig Blu-rays.
This is great.
But for us digital distribution
outlets, as well
as consumers in general, this
isn't a good thing.
Waiting for 17 to 40 gigabytes
worth of data to play your
game is not good at all.
It takes time.
It creates a lag between what
the user's expectation is and
pay rate is to when
they actually
experience the content.
And there's a large gap there
that is directly correlated to
how many users buy your game,
how many users continue to
play your game, and how many
users just get stopped at the
front door.
And as we all know, especially
the Indies that may be in the
audience today, that's
huge, right?
You want these people
giving you money.
And creating barriers to their
experience is a bad thing.
So we talk about texture
compression systems because we
want to avoid 17 gigabytes,
right?
We want to move down.
You need to look at
it as a triangle.
For instance, this is a nice
little understanding here.
And again, we're talking about
texture decompression, so
we're talking about the runtime
decompressing of textures.
It's kind of a performance
triangle where you need to
optimize, based upon your game
and your title, between the
quality of the decompressed
image, the size and the
footprint of the in-memory
representation and then how
fast you can actually decompress
that data.
And depending on your game,
you'll find a different point
on this triangle.
So for some of Id stuff,
you may be more towards
decompression speed and
size than quality.
For FarmVille, obviously, you
would want quality and size as
a better metric.
Maybe speed is not as
big of an issue.
Who knows?
But you really need to take
this triangle into thought
when you're talking about
decompression and algorithms
in general.
And hopefully, you'll think
about this while we're talking
about our stuff today too.
So the state-of-the-art for this
process, let's talk about
what you all are
already doing.
So you should all know this.
You should all be familiar with
this as we start forward.
So the way that people handle
textures today is the artist
usually generates some PSD
file in Photoshop.
This PSD file is converted to a
DXT texture, either through
Microsoft's tool, or
NVIDIA tools, or
Compressonator from AMD, ATI.
And then that data is usually
just thrown, batch process
ad-hoc, into a zip file or
some sort of compressed,
binary archive.
And then that archive is then
put on disk or put into
memory, shipped out
with the product.
And when a level load or the
game loads, usually what
happens is the zip
file is opened up
in memory at runtime.
The entire zip archive is either
loaded into memory or
kept on disk and then
streamed from.
And that data is copied right
from the memory, or right from
the compressed version,
right to the GPU.
So the DXT data that's in the
archive and in memory just
gets, effectively,
mem copied over.
And this is usually fine.
But the problem here is that you
don't want to always keep
this process going because,
when you open your zip
archive, you either keep the
entire thing in memory or you
keep it all on disc and
stream from it.
And the point here is that you
should not keep your entire
zip in archive.
I remember, in my previous life,
we were putting out a
console title on the Xbox 360.
And we had archives
around four gigs.
Well, the problem was the
hardware we were working on
only had 512 megs of RAM that
we could actually work with.
So obviously, keeping the entire
thing in memory is not
a good idea.
On the other side of this,
actually hitting the optical
disk to stream in your data is
not always available as well.
In addition to that, some of the
data that exists in your
archive is not actually
needed.
So for instance, let's say
you're loading a level, right?
When you load a level, there's
going to be lots of data.
There's going to be bounding
volume hierarchies, quad
trees, navigational meshes.
There's going to be animations
for characters.
Some of this stuff can actually
be loaded once and
then thrown away, while
other items and other
representations need to be
loaded and continuously used.
And this is where you get the
divide between load and forget
and then load and
continue using
between data and textures.
So you kind of go, OK, well, if
I have a zip archive that
represents level seven and I
only need to use the first 25%
during load time, and then the
rest of it I need at runtime
for textures or whatever,
then it makes sense to
segment that out.
And say, OK, well, here's
the pre-load
stuff for level seven.
And then, here's the runtime
And then there's sort of a
rabbit hole that, once you
start thinking about this, you
go down this rabbit hole.
And you end up in
utter madness.
But you don't get the free tea
or the cool hat or the rabbit
running around.
But you get the craziness of
the experience because what
happens is you start to bin-sort
all of your content
around and figure out these
optimal solutions.
That's really just madness.
Really, what you should be doing
is you should find a way
to hyper compress your textures
so that they turn
into a load-once solution.
And the rest of this talk is
going to be focused explicitly
on this sort of technique.
The idea here is that you're
going to want to hyper
compress your textures in some
way that you can load them
into main memory and keep them
in main memory for the entire
duration of the game, or the
level, or what you need.
And then, on-demand, decompress
them from whatever
format they're in
to a GPU format.
And then throw them
away, if you need.
And this is actually a very
powerful instance, right?
IDtech5 has made waves
with this.
I've been hearing about
MegaTexture for almost six
years, I think, seven years
has been the big thing.
And RAGE has finally shipped.
And you can go play the game
and see the RAGE of IDtech5
and what happens.
Basically, they realized
that this was a
problem early on, right?
They had tons and tons
of texture data.
And the way that they handled
this was they stored the
textures in this hyper
compressed format.
Basically, some of their early
papers by Van Waveren--
you can find them on the
Intel Developer site--
actually talk about creating a
variant of JPEG, which is a
DCT block-based format, and
actually compressing them to
DXT at runtime.
So basically, offline, they
would compress them into this
lossy-style format, DCT.
And then, at runtime, they'd
take that DCT data and then
convert it over to DXT, which
was then mem copied to the
GPU, right?
The cool thing about this is,
according to their research,
they were getting about 112
megapixels or megatexles a
second on dual core.
That's a lot of megapixels,
megatexles a second.
That's a lot of texture data to
be effectively streaming,
converting and moving around.
Some of the down-sides of this,
though, aren't really
that published.
But when you actually start
implementing that algorithm
and realizing what's going on
here, or if you've spend a lot
of time with texture
compression, you first realize
that this is very processor
intensive.
You're spending a lot of
CPU time redoing the
same sort of work.
You're taking a DCT texture,
converting it to DXT.
In addition to that, this
actually converts and
introduces 2 times the
amount of noise.
DCT actually is a lossy codec.
It's a lossy form.
So what happens is, when you
compress your texture, it's
going to introduce noise
into the texture.
And then, when you decompress
the texture to compress it to
DXT, DXT is also
a lossy format.
So what's happening is you're
introducing error, reverting
that error, but keeping it
around to some respect and
then introducing new
error again.
So you're actually getting 2
times the amount of error in
your image during the
compression process.
In addition to that, because
of the fact that the DXT
conversion is happening at
runtime, it means that you
can't spend a ton of time
optimizing for how your DXT
blocks should be considered,
right?
Basically, you have to resort
to a box fit or a best fit
algorithm, which might not
actually produce the best
color correlation ratio.
There's tons of algorithms
out there.
We're going to talk about some
today that allow you to get a
better quality, if you're
working at it offline.
So here's the idea.
Here the whole point of this
talk that I'd like to talk
about today.
So what if we approach this
from a different angle?
What if, instead of taking an
existing compressed form,
decompressing it and translating
it into DXT at
runtime, what if we started with
the DXT data initially?
And we took that DXT data, and
we hyper compressed it?
So we hyper compress the DXT
data more, such that, at
runtime, all we're doing is a
decompression step to get us
our original DXT input.
So this is the idea.
The idea is that we don't
introduce any new error data
with this because it's just
going from something
compressed back to DXT.
And then we can actually store
this in memory, hyper
compressed.
So we load it from our zip file,
keep it in some section
of memory that we're not
using all the time.
And then we decompress directly
to DXT whenever our
view frustum changes, or we have
a cache invalidation, or
we do a flush, or something
along those lines.
So in order to test if this is
the right direction to go, we
need some sort of test images
to prove both decompression
time and size and speeds
and whatnot like that.
So anytime you're doing image
compression block tests, you
have to produce some sort of
conical representation
to take a look at.
So what I've created is
actually a random
collection of images.
All images behave differently.
I think it would be
irresponsible on my side to
just use one type of image.
So I've actually included a
bunch of images in my set from
different things.
Some are from games--
the actual PSD, the source
images, the TGAs uncompressed.
So there's no noise
being added there.
Some are public.
For example, the famous Lena
image, which, if you don't
know who Lena is in respect to
compression, please go take a
look at it.
And some are from
image libraries.
The Kodak Image Library
is actually fantastic.
It's a lot of high-resolution
images that are great to test
against your own compression
algorithms.
And then all of the numbers I'm
going to be showing today
for these compression processes
actually include the
DDS headers, which is
about 128 bytes.
So this is going to skew
the results slightly.
But if you take that into
account, you have to have the
header of the texture, how big
it is, how many MIPs it is,
what the format is, all
these other things.
So take that in.
And then, any percentage values
that I produce on my
slides are actually in
amount of reduction.
This is basically saying, how
much has been reduced from the
original format so that you're
seeing this large delta to see
what we're saving as all of
these things come together.
So before we move on,
let's take a look at
a typical DXT block.
And for the sake of this talk,
I'm going to focus on DXT1
because, I think, understanding
it from here
allows us to launch off the
different algorithms, DXT3, 5,
DXTN, all these other
sorts of things.
So a DXT block is constructed
likewise.
First off, it starts by storing
a high color and a low
color in a 5-6-5 bit poly.
That's red, green, blue
5-bit, 6-bits, 5 bits.
What these two colors represent
in space is
effectively the endpoints
of a line.
You can see that, these two
large circles here.
Then what you end up with is,
with these two high- and
low-colors, you end up with
a 4x4 block of pixels.
These 4x4 block effectively
only contains
two bits per cell.
And the two bits actually
represent a discrete step
between these two endpoints
in color space, right?
So you can see on the image
here, we've got some random
assortment of colors that
are off the line.
And effectively, they
get snapped to one
of these four values.
This is the heart of
DXT compression.
It allows for a really fast
load, really fast filtering.
It allows you to keep a lot of
blocks in a mem cache line on
the GPU, which is really
important.
And in general, it doesn't
actually reduce
the quality too much.
But it is lossy, so it does
introduce some error.
So let's look at the initial
data set for DXT.
The uncompressed images
are around 37 megs.
This is just the source image,
non-compressed, right?
And I could have chosen a
bigger data set size.
But every time I would run
this set, it takes 15, 20
minutes to actually run
and get the results.
And I've got stuff to do today,
so I can't have a
200-megabyte set.
DXT1, if I just take the source
data and compress it
into DXT1, it gets it down to
about 7.6 megs, which is good.
That's fantastic.
That's exactly the type of
compression size you want to
see out of DXT.
If we zip that data, so we do
whatever everyone in the room
is already doing.
We just take that DXT
data, throw into an
archive, and zip it.
That ends up at about 4.82
megs, or about 36%, 37%
savings, which is good.
It means we're getting
that in addition
to what we're getting.
Now as a form of comparison,
just to look at things a
different way, if we actually
compressed each of the DXT
images individually by zipping
them, we get about 5.1 megs.
Now notice this is higher.
The reason for this is because
we're adding all of the
additional zip data overhead.
So we're adding the headers,
the span chunks, all these
other fun things.
And there's some other
interesting nuances of why
that footprint is higher that
I'll get to a little bit later
in the talk.
The goal for this talk, though,
is to beat this.
We want our compression
algorithm to match what zip is
creating, so that our in memory
version is the same
footprint size as what
we would expect
our of our zip file.
So the goal is can
we get to that?
Can we beat 36.83%
for our hyper
compressed format in memory?
To do this, I'm going to present
you a bag of tricks.
And these are all separate
items. I'm going to talk about
how each one of these items
changes the footprint size,
the memory size, and then
present them individually so
that you can mix and match them,
depending on your input.
So for lossless algorithms, so
these are algorithms that do
not introduce any new errors
into the image.
The first one we're going to
cover is de-interleaving.
I'll talk about that
in a minute.
The next one, of course,
is Huffman compression.
Everyone in here, if you have
a basic computer science
degree, you should have written
a Huffman before.
The next one is delta
encoding.
This is sort of a tricky
thing that not a lot of
people are aware of.
And then, finally, we're going
to talk about codebooks and
what codebooks are and
how you can use them.
Now to really get some amazing
results, we're going to also
talk about one specific
lossy technique.
And this is actually going to
be an expanding blocks, aka
region of interest-based
finding pattern.
And I think you'll love what
we come out of that.
But we're going to save
until the end because
it's the big review.
So let's start the top
with de-interleaving.
Again, as mentioned before, here
is a standard DXT block.
You've got your high-color and
your low-color and your 4x4
set of selector bits.
Now in memory, in GPU memory,
CPU memory and on-disk in a
DDS format, effectively,
you concatenate
these blocks in memory.
So you've got your high-color,
low-color selector bits,
high-color, low-color selector
bits, high-color, low-color
selector bits.
The ideal with de-interleaving
is what if we actually
separated those out?
What if we put all of our high
and low colors together, and
then put all of the selector
bits together?
The intent here is that, for
zip compression, which is
basically a modified version
of LZW, what they create is
actually a window.
And they say, we're
going to analyze.
And we're going to deflate--
it's another compression
algorithm-- we're going to
deflate everything within this
window, and then move on to
the next window and deflate
everything in that window.
So by de-interleaving our
data, putting all of our
colors and then all of our
selector bits in, effectively,
two separate bins, what we're
trying to do here is optimize
for the zip compression
format.
So we're trying to pack as much
duplicate data into each
one of those sliding windows
as we can to, hopefully,
increase the amount of
compression we get.
So let's check out what
that looks like.
So with DXTi, I've got each
one of these techniques
segmented out with a different
enunciation at the top.
So de-interleaving, so again
the DXT1 original footprint
was 7.63 megs.
The interleaved version
is 7.63 megs.
Now again, no compression
has occurred here.
All we've done here is just
moved around the selector bits
and color bits so that they're
homogeneous in
their sorting here.
Now the zip here is fantastic.
We've actually went
to 43% savings.
Now if you remember, this is
basically about a 10%, I
think, savings here.
This is fantastic.
This is the end result.
So simply by de-interleaving
your data, you get about 10%
savings there, which is good.
A 10%, 15% savings there,
which is fantastic.
And this is optimized, so
this is exactly what
we wanted to see.
So that's good.
The next question is, can we
reduce the amount of unique
data in the sliding window
even further?
Such that zip can compress
it even further?
To do that, we're going to look
at a common compression
technique called Huffman.
Now Huffman is effectively a
dictionary creation system.
So dictionary systems all work
in a very specific way.
Effectively, they create a
dictionary symbol of unique
values that exist
in the stream.
And then they replace the
instance of that symbol in the
data stream with a
minimal bit-code
representation of that.
So for instance, Morse code is
a perfect example of that.
They analyzed the English
language.
And they said, E is the most
common character in the
English language.
Therefore, we're going
to represent E
with a single beep.
So then, any time you're doing
scans and whatnot, E is
represented in the least
value possible.
For an example of this, let's
say we've got this string,
four A's, two B's and a C, which
is, with 8-bit ASCII is
about 56 bits, right?
In Huffman, if you just looked
at the compression stream, A
is going to be the most
common symbol.
So it's only going to
get the zero bit.
B is the second most symbol,
so it's going
to get the one bits.
And then C is the third
symbol here, so it's
going to get two bits.
So we go from 56
bits to 8 bits.
And I there's some of you in the
audience who are saying,
actually, that should be
a little bit different,
depending on which Huffman
version you use.
We're going to use this
is an illustration.
Please consult Wikipedia for
all the different versions
that you can find
about Huffman.
It's actually staggering how
many different versions of
Huffman are out there.
So make sure you're tuning
that as you see fit.
So let's look at what
this did to us.
So we've got DXTih.
So this is de-interleaving
plus Huffman.
And also, I want to point out
at the top here, I'm noting
that Huffman and the usage of
Huffman requires you to define
a symbol size.
Now for this test here, I've
actually chosen 16-bit symbols
for my colors and 8-bit symbols
for my selectors.
And this has a big bearing on
how things work, right?
If I were to use 16-bit for
selectors, I get less value.
If I use 8-bits for colors,
I get less compression, et
cetera, et cetera.
So let's take a look at this.
So the standard again,
7.63 megs for DXT.
DXTdih, so de-interleaved
with Huffman
encoding, is about 40%.
So this is not as good
as we saw before.
We're introducing a little bit
of noise into the stream here.
When you add in the
zip, though,
you get back to about--
we only get about 1% savings
by adding the Huffman.
So we didn't get much benefit.
One important note here is
though, that again, this is
optimized for your
colors up top.
And basically, what
I was doing was
optimizing for my set.
Now if you take that into
account, what you should
really be doing is finding
the optimal bit encoding.
For what I did this test,
I just used a
8-bit row, 4x4 block.
So I just took the 4x4 and just
made that one symbol.
In reality, you should scan your
data input to determine
what the optimal combination
provides.
So the blog, [? Seibey ?]
Live--
you can see the link at the
bottom of the slide there--
did a similar test where they
basically figured out what the
multiple pairings were to
determine the best symbol
orientation for this exact
type of compression.
In their particular data set
that they were using, they
found that 2x2 blocks of
selector bits produced the
highest number of duplicate
symbols.
You can see that as the high
value there in the frequency.
In reality, before you actually
compress your data,
you should be doing this.
You should be going through, per
texture, finding out what
the optimal solution is
and compressing that.
And in reality, you should all
have build farms in here.
This is the modern gaming age.
You should have some ability to
kick off a nightly build to
a farm of servers that
bake all your data.
So the processing involved
with generating this data
should not be that
important to you.
So Huffman provided great
reduction for the base stream,
but didn't provide too much
help with our zip
compression, right?
So we got our base data
compressed very nicely.
But when you put zip on top
of it, we didn't see
too much of a help.
Now this is OK.
This is what we want, right?
We want that base, non-zipped,
compressed data to start
getting lower so
it matches zip.
So delta encoding, let's
talk about this.
Delta encoding will effectively
encode a stream of
data by replacing each element
in the stream with a value
that represents the data
from the previous sum.
The goal here is to reduce the
dynamic range of symbols that
could exist in the
stream, right?
And so Huffman encoding will
basically replace the symbols
in the stream, based upon
frequency, with minimal bit
representations.
Delta encoding will scan through
the string before that
and, basically, truncate,
concatenate and quantize to
create more of the low-band,
unique signals.
A perfect example
of this this.
So we've got this string here,
or this set of numbers, 155,
156, yada, yada, yada.
Now if we just threw this at
Huffman, the only symbols that
we would find here as duplicates
are basically, the
157's right there.
Huffman would say that's the
most frequent symbol, that
would get the lowest bit-set.
Now if we run this through delta
encoding first, what
happens is we create 155,
1, 1, 0, 0, 64, 1, 3.
So basically, what you're seeing
here is that what we do
is we say, the first
symbol is 155.
The next symbol is add one.
The next symbol to that is
add one to that value.
The next symbol to that is add
zero, add zero, add 64, add
one, add three.
What we've done here,
effectively, is increased the
number of duplicate symbols in
the stream by encoding the
delta between the values, as
opposed to the actual values
themselves.
So this decreases the dynamic
range of the stream.
So let's see how this
did for us.
So DXTihd with delta encoding.
Base, again, 7.63 megs,
non-zipped.
So just taking the DXT data
itself about 41%.
That's good, right?
And about 45% reduction for
the zipped version.
And that's great, right?
The problem here is is we're
starting to see this plateau.
We're not getting
huge results by
squeezing this stream itself.
It might be worth looking at
a different direction.
And with that, we take
a look at codebooks.
Effectively, we create a
codebook by scanning the DXT
image and create a codebook
that lists all the unique
symbols, sort of like the
dictionary method.
And then we delta encode
those unique values.
Then in the DST block stream--
so basically, we create
all the this
unique stream of colors.
We delta encode that.
And then, in the block stream,
we go back and we list a
256-bit index into
this codebook.
Now, of course, some of you in
the audience should say, hey,
wait a minute.
What if you've got more
than 256 colors?
That's OK.
What we actually do is we
create a sliding window
approach to ensure that you'll
always have a 256-bit index.
So basically, what we do is, for
the entire list of colors
in your codebook, you basically
say, I'm going to
create a window of the
first 256 values.
Those will be numbered zero to
255, then the next set of 256,
and then the next set of 256,
and the next set of 256.
And then, in your actual index
data stream, you're going to
make a reference into the proper
bin of 256 values.
And there's some interesting
ways to make
sure that this works.
There's lots of stuff
on Wikipedia.
I would highly recommend you go
take a look at that because
I don't have time today to
explain the specific nuances.
So with that, we actually got
some different results.
It gave some really good ones.
So first off, we're at 46%
without zip compression--
that's pretty amazing--
and 49% with zip compression.
So we're still sort of chasing
the dragon of zip compression
and trying to track that down.
But again, we're not seeing the
huge jumps in savings that
we're expecting.
Or we haven't broken that 50%.
And there's got to be a
better way to do that.
And with that, we're going to
talk about expanding blocks.
Now this is a lossy technique,
but I think you're going to
like the results.
And so that's why I want
to bring it up today.
So the point here is that
adjacent DXT cells often share
color profiles.
So 4x4 and the block next to it
and the block below it and
block in an adjacent direction
to it, they're--
the way that artists and
pictures work, the number of
pixels we have on a screen,
chances are, those colors are
all correlated.
So what if we used an 8x8
cell instead of a 4x4?
Just hypothetically?
We stored one high- and
low-color per 8x8.
And then we stored six
64 two-bit selectors.
What would this do
to our image?
What would the results be?
Well, let's take
a look at that.
What you're seeing on the screen
here is two images.
The left is the original.
The right has been compressed
with 8x8 blocks instead of 4x4
DXT blocks.
From this distance, you
really shouldn't
see much of a problem.
You can see a little bit of
banding, a little bit
quantization, maybe some blocks
for the full image.
But in general, you shouldn't
see anything wrong.
It's not until we zoom in that
you actually start seeing
problems. And even here, it's
pretty hard to notice.
I want to point out where
the errors are here.
If you look at the top of the
bird's beak, you can see some
blocking artifacts there.
You can see some graininess at
the bottom of the background.
You see the quantization of
the steps of colors there.
But in general, this
image performs
very well at 8x8 blocks.
Here's another example.
This is from the Kodak
suite as well.
At this distance, you
really shouldn't
see much of a problem.
Again, this is 8x8 block
compressed, right?
We actually see less problems
than the parrot because
there's a lot less smooth
gradients in this image.
And there's more general
sub-noise, which helps hide
the DXT artifacts.
Now when we zoom in on her
chin, you actually start
seeing the problems
pretty badly.
Here, you actually see the block
and the color truncation
on her necklace as well as some
clipping on her chin there.
You can actually see these
problems. But again, you have
to zoom in all the way
to look at these.
Now if someone's chasing you
around with a rocket launcher
at 60 frames a second, you're
probably not going to care.
Here's a trick question.
Which one's compressed?
Now this is an in-game
texture.
So this is something
you would see.
This is something that artists
would generate to put in your
environment.
Which one of these
is compressed?
Well, of course, with this
normal trend, the one on the
left is the original and the
one on the right is the
compressed version.
But could you really tell,
especially with
this type of image?
Even when we zoom in, can you
tell which one of these has
been quantized 8x8 blocks
and which hasn't?
So let's look at the
results here.
This is awesome.
With 8x8 blocks explicitly--
so we're using 8x8 blocks
everywhere--
we actually end up with our
zipped and our non-zipped
memory footprint at exactly the
same size, 67.7% savings,
taking the original 37
megs down to 2.46.
This is exactly what we were
looking for in this research.
We were trying to find a way
to make the uncompressed
version in memory match what
we get out of a zip.
And we did it by combining
Huffman encoding,
deinterlacing, and
doing 8x8 blocks.
It's fantastic.
Oh, as well as codebooks.
So now let's talk about
everyone else in here.
So you remember that
triangle, right?
So everyone else in
here is say well,
what about the triangle?
We've gotten speed, and
we've gotten quality--
or we've gotten compression size
and we've gotten quality.
Now let's talk about speed.
So for this style I just
showed you, which is
de-interleaving, Huffman
and [? styles ?]
delta encoding of codebooks with
8x8 blocks, using CS101
Huffman and delta encoding.
So I didn't do anything
special here.
I didn't spend any time
optimizing my Huffman
decompression or my
delta encoding.
I just threw it in there.
With about 67.8% savings,
I was getting about 73
megapixels a second
on a single core.
So this was one core doing this
compression, which is
fantastic, right?
If you go to two cores,
that's 114.
Three cores, you start getting
into some of the numbers that
you start seeing here.
The cool thing here is that
that's 1.32 bits per pixel.
That's fantastic.
DXT is four bits per pixel.
And with this technique, we
get it down to about 1.32.
That's awesome.
So here's the big
reveal, right?
This is the entire thing.
Why stop at 8x8 blocks?
What if we actually modified our
image heuristics to scan,
based upon the frequency of the
image, and use somewhere
between four and 16x16 blocks?
We do the same thing.
We de-interleave, delta encode
and Huffman encode them.
With this, we get about 80%
reduction at 93 megapixels a
second for diffuse
textures only.
And that gets us down to
0.8 bits per pixel.
That is amazing.
For one core, you're telling
me I can get
0.8 bits per pixel.
And I can decompress 93
megatexles a second.
That's awesome.
This is fantastic, right?
Of course, you have to do all
this stuff offline and
compress it properly.
But that's a separate thing.
So the bigger reveal is that,
once I came to all this
research and got all this stuff
done a couple of days
later, a very young, friendly
gentleman named Rich
Geldreich, who I've worked with
at my previous companies,
decided to put his
CRUNCH codec--
which is his version of texture
compression-- online.
It's licensed very generally.
You should go check it out.
Click that link there
and go check it out.
He does about the same, about
between 0.8 and 1.25 bits per
pixel for his texture
compression for diffuse textures.
For normal textures, he gets
about 1.75 to 2 bits per
pixel, which is still
really amazing.
This is cutting edge for game
textures, without having to go
through a full JPEG
2000 stack.
The thing here that is different
is that he gets
about 256 megatexles a second
decompression, single core.
I was only able to get 93.
So he's got some dark
voodoo in there that
really changes the game.
Again, his stuff is up
on code.google.com.
You can get it.
You can use it in your game.
I forget what the
licenses are.
But you should definitely
go check that out.
So take aways, it's actually
easy to get really simple
savings with really simple
algorithms, if you just
concatenate them in
the right way.
Most importantly, your mileage
may vary for texture types.
What works for an ambient
occlusion texture really well
may not work for
a DXT texture.
So it's important to optimize
and combine each of these
things to put them together
to figure out what texture
profile works best for you.
And it's best to spend offline
doing your compression.
You want to spend all of your
time online, while the game is
running, while you're fighting
for that 16 millisecond frame
to get you 60 Hertz, you want
all of that time to go towards
what you need.
You don't want to be spending
a lot of time decompressing
and compressing.
So do all of your compression
offline.
And do your decompression
online.
So that's it for me.
Big thanks to Rich Geldreich,
John Brooks and Ken Adams for
their help in this talk.
You can see our final
table here.
And feel free to contact me
any time you nee need
questions, colton@google.com.
Thank you all, very much.
Have a good day.